steht doch junge war ich laufe um ihn
herum die sonst was alter was man junge
es hakt des todes ich kann ich bei feine
schließlich kann ich genau ich schieß
auf ihn drauf die ganze zeit und nichts
passiert weil dieser scheiß läufer hat
wie ich jetzt zweimal gestoppt
chillig habt ihr nicht des todes hey
leute und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge rage mortier auf dem golm hd
server natürlich einige server wo man
richmond trifft ich spielen kann und wo
es vor ort gibt die an meiner stimme
wahrscheinlich gehört wenn ich werde
krank wir suchen immer ganz kurze server
so warte ich jetzt noch keiner drin sein
ich bin der bbe krank ist hat man ein
asus hat man meine stimme dass man in
allem einfach und deswegen bin ich mega
scheiße drauf weil ich einfach ich muss
mal so viel hausaufgaben machen die
klausurphase geht bald wieder los mit
ihrem studium kümmern und alles um alex
einfach im moment und deswegen dachte
ich mir woran soll ich mein mut wohl
auslassen außer an einer von rage mode
einige meinten alle meinten unter letzte
in der letzten folge dass ich eine neue
folge machen soll ein paar meint auch zu
dass alles nur gestellt also der sinn
der grund warum radsport zu selten kommt
ist einfach weil ich das halt nur
aufnehmen wenn ich mich gerade gegen das
aufnehmen aufregen kann und das ist halt
jetzt wieder der fall weil ich einfach
über das kranke an der nase weg
das sprechen tut auch weh und zurzeit
geht es halt noch allerdings vielleicht
dann gleich noch ein spiel weniger zeit
verdeckt dann als ich weiß nicht ob es
hört aber irgendwie hier nebenan
schreibt grübel laut um eine bande keine
ahnung ob fußball widerspiegelt in 50
und auch schon los
so jetzt mal kurz als mehr drin ist
irgendwann gegner daten gegner
[ __ ] altern ich werde erstmal direkt
mein schneeball weg nein ein junger
direkt tötet er mich alter warum kann
ich denn überhaupt steber wegwerfen wenn
ich nicht mehr drin bin denn der
studienwahl losgegangen ist alter was
sollen die scheiße also sorry wenn ich
zwischendurch immer so ein bisschen als
stabil ein bisschen schnee für durch mal
nase durch autos so noch mehr auf morgen
so du willst ein neues modell ja auch
total.com los komm auf geht's jungs so
dahinter ist auch wieder einer sozia
kamen hier nicht willkommen die keine
ahnung so auch tot so wir sind ein
relativ gut wir sind zweiter wiese -
weiter für der erste 1 ist ein erster
nähe wir sind fast erste und wieder
hinbekommt etwas man feiere ich hab grad
einer komponenten so du bist auftut
du bist auch tod du nicht warum nicht
also ich klicke auf ihn drauf und ich
habe den stil war dann eben als ich hab
dir noch auf die drauf geworfen so
kommentiert nee nee nee ist einfach
nicht annimmst nicht an los genau genau
richtig ich schieße sie ab 1000 mal
schlag auf die drobs passiert nix nix
postierter chile sterben alte duo so
sind wir zweiter kommen versuchen wir
erster zu werden wenn wir erster werden
dann ja ihr könnt auf jeden fall wieder
daumen runter lassen denn euch diese
serie gefällt das zeigt mir dass es euch
gefällt wenn nicht ausrasten ließ ich
bin ja gerade so gut
so kommen du kriegst jetzt auch erstmal
eine mit dass sie so butz so bin ich
auch erst ich bin ich erst mit zehn zu
drei dass sogar der beste kaffee fast
bleibt stehen du verdammte sei so auf
tod kontrakt seit 15 killstreak alter
läuft bei ihm also bei mir so ich kann
mich irgendwie gar nicht aufregen weil
ich kann relativ gut wird und ich habe
viel abbekommen
richtig schwierig so die leute die von
hinten abschließend jetzt meinte die
sinti pro schild ich habe elf zuviel
wieso bin ich denn nicht erst da ich
habe elf ach so der jetzt an der 12
das system deckt sich nicht ab gehören
falschen fall so zog man natürlich den
schneeball genau richtig chillig alter
gelbes zone tod so hier sport der
nächste laser so natürlich hier schnell
zwischen so auch tot
auch tot nein nein nein nein
los jetzt hinter jost von der seite von
der seite von der leyen ein mann du
jetzt ja ich komme rein eine
millisekunde später bin ich tot weil ich
ein pfeil trifft eigentlich in anderen
bestimmt war
verpiss dich alter direkt geht alle
schläge nur auf mich wieder chillig alte
geil auf jeden fall so dur
schneeballwurf ins gesicht alter direkt
junge da gehört er hin
so bekommst auch ist man voll rein so
seine hinter mir jetzt nicht so ist ja
da drin ist auch katrin schilling sport
einfach keiner mehr bei mir geil freut
mich sagt kooths wenn man stehen bleibt
ist natürlich klar wenn man lerne
natürlich logisch
nein warum sie trifft einfach aus drei
metern braucht einfach nennen der
ansparzeit von einer millisekunde alter
wie wie so du kriegst ein schneeball
trifft treffer nicht so tot
da habe ich den ersten getötet ja geil
geil er trifft einfach auslosen
millimeter schillig alter halt dein maul
verfickte suchen schwein man junge junge
alle beleidigungen nicht ernst nehmen
doch neben der einzige was sind das denn
für spaß dies vor allem dieser eine tote
als ich bin zweiter ich habe 20 zu 10 kg
junge bei mir läuft übels steht doch
junge warum ich laufe um ihn rum wie
sonstwas alter was man ja junge endlich
klimawandel
alter alter alter
das kann nicht sein das kann nicht sein
ich laufe um ihn rum ich schlag des
todes jetzt auch wieder und der trip er
stirbt einfach nicht an ihr könnt mir
nicht sagen das ist der falsche
geschwindigkeit von mir war oder dass
ich einen zu langen abstand hatte das
kann nicht sein das kann auch nicht sein
dass der ecke sprintet uns mich einfach
abschießt es kann nicht sein
stirb alter das hätte ich noch
verstanden weil da war wirklich eine
komische entfernung von menschen aber
ich stehe direkt neben ihm der stirbt
nicht
junge mann ich meine dieser modus ist
geil aber man könnte sich einfach so
darüber aufregen die ganze zeit so kommt
ja ich hab auch völlig du stets auch so
vor als hätte sich das war mega unnötig
dann müsste einer hier drin sein nächst
nicht das pony der mittlerweile nadal
los los los kommt der ziel so rund
ich krieg die krise ich krieg die krise
ich schießen zentimeter über ihm und es
wird nicht gezählt schlag auf ihn drauf
und es wird nicht gezählt
schillig alter chillige spiel gefällt
mir richtig gut mag ich richtig gerade
ich bin immer noch zweiter habe ich
verstehe ehrlich gesagt nicht warum bei
ich glaub mega schlecht bin denn wäre
das der erste auch mega steckt ja ja ja
genau
fährt er erst baut einfach dreht sich
direkt um sieht mich halt direkt einfach
junge geiler typ alter geil bist du wenn
wir müssen jetzt mal wieder hier bin
warum warum trifft der schläger denn
junge was ist das denn für nur noch 15
schneeball hier ja geil
chillig alter cooler typ sollte jetzt
auch wieder mehr mit dem boden herum
foto koni halt dein maul man wenn ich
sport spiele dann bin ich auch drauf
dann sollten wir nichts liebe schreiben
so kommen
diese treffe ich denen nicht das war
doch gut geschossen tot war und jetzt
wieder einer jaja kommt 9a hat er
natürlich gute reflexe gezeigt der
herner junge der start der stark der
rigi der erster der vier plätze tillich
du stehst auf ich bin immer noch zweifel
erster werden aber ich kann nicht erst
werden wir einfach mal sechs tote
weniger hatte sich zuletzt ein nein das
ist immer dieser penner dieser erste der
mich immer klingt junge scheiße mann das
würde ich mich fassen mit der eigenen
explosion wo ich dachte schon
ich habe dir doch getroffen ich habe die
anzeige da drauf würdet ihr das sehen
wir in lucka teil läuft bei mir auf
jeden fall
ich muss zwei mal auf den draufschlagen
damit der stirbt irgendwie scheiße dass
der bitze junge es hakt des todes ich
kann nicht auf eine schiefe ich kann
nicht mehr genau
ich schieß auf ihn drauf die ganze zeit
und nichts passiert weil dieser scheiß
server hat wie jetzt zweimal gestoppt
schillig habt ihr nicht des todes ja
geiler server geil
chillig alles fand hier wieder die
anderen holen auf geil das ist ja das
ist richtig gut gefällt mir richtig
stirbt doch man ich gehe es in wetter
ich gehe einfach ist in wertach ich
schieße und es passiert einfach nichts
mehr galt megageil achtens vorbei und
wie viel ich wurde wieder dritter junger
ich habe die meisten kills im kompletten
spiel und ich wurde wieder dritter
junger es kann doch echt nicht sein ich
die meisten kills waren echt so
unverdient ich schlage einfach auf die
tropfen ist passiert einfach nichts
es passiert einfach nichts ich weiß
nicht einmal im internet liegt ob das
spiel modus liegt auf seine kraft die
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht ob es gesund
ist was ich gerade gemacht habe und es
war auch nicht jetzt so rage mäßig wie
beim ersten mal war ich einfach mega
krank war aber trotzdem wenn ihr noch
eine weitere folge rage sehen wollt
irgendwann noch mal die alten ort
wichtig wie ich weiß viel geschrieben
hat oder sogar dass du dich in den kopf
schoss
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt absolut
richtig weh ich leide hier für euch
alter kommt springt um mich herum genau
wenn ihr noch mehr davon sehen wollen
von diesem scheiße scheiße blablabla
dann schafft ihnen die weisen nicht
20.000 leidenschaft 6000 und dann sind
wir mal darüber schreibt auf jeden fall
mal alle in die kommentare
weil immer als sich getötet wurde das
drama und sohn schreibt ihnen gleich
beleidigung irgendwelche kreativen
beleidigungen der kommentare die besten
eher wenig dann und dann sehen wir es
irgendwann mal wieder um einen ort sowie
ich glaub ich jetzt erstmal in was rein
alters kann - sein